I knew I was passionate about makeup but
I didn't know I could have fun every day
doing my job
normal is very boring and I feel like
I'm not normal and I'm blessed to be not
normal I'm definitely a last minute
person need motivation what's your
timetable believe nation what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a woman who went from being on a
reality TV show Keeping Up with the
Kardashians to becoming one of the most
influential teens in the world and is on
track to become the youngest billionaire
in history
she's Kylie Jenner and here's my take on
her top ten rules of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one do what you love I think I struggled
for a minute with finding something to
do on my own and what was I gonna do I
knew I was passionate about makeup but I
didn't know I could have fun every day
doing my job
I had an insecurity with my lips when I
was younger so I turned to makeup to
help me feel more confident I went to
the makeup store and I just like I
didn't even know really what colors I
was picking I was just like I want some
lip liner that looks like the color of
my lips because I just want my lips to
look fuller but I could never find a lip
liner and a lipstick that matched or
even the right color that was perfect
for me so that's where the lip kit
started I was so focused on like formula
and color but everything else just kind
of fell into place I put so much love
into everything that I make and I make
sure everything is perfect and something
I would personally use so then when I
see my fans have it and they love it and
their reaction that's what's the most
exciting to me if I could give some
advice let's do something that you love
if you're building something from the
ground up like do something that you're
passionate about so you just have fun
every day and you love what you do
rule number two be different I have
never felt insecure
I still feel insecure all the time I
feel like it's just a part of being a
human being I feel like I just learned
that normal it's very boring
and I feel like I'm not normal and I'm
blessed to be not normal and just be
different and I feel like if you're
different or if you think something
about you
is just weird and out of the ordinary I
think that's so dope so hold on to it
rule number three explore new things you
come up with the idea of coming up with
an app I think my whole family we always
knew we wanted to make kind of a
platformer that wasn't Instagram or
Twitter just something that was totally
ourselves inorganic and I just always
wanted to share more with my fans I just
didn't know how so now it's just such an
easy way to do I want to do beauty tips
every day and like all my looks for less
and yeah I'm just always doing fun
videos and you have a schedule you have
your outfit of the day and yeah style
yeah and then you film some bits so it
doesn't take a lot of work to manage
your app it takes so much work it's like
it's like producing your own reality
television show you have to always keep
people interested it's hard but it's fun
isn't it rule number four own your
mistakes starting a company on my own
and it being so big from the beginning
there's not a lot of room for mistakes
every company has mistakes they learn
from them and they change them but it's
probably owning up to those from the
beginning and just being honest and
changing them in front of everybody I'm
the face to my brand and I take
responsibility for everything that
happens rule number five staying for
something you are so outspoken about and
I would think that you are aware of
bullying because you talked about when
you're this public and when you're this
high up on a pedestal there gonna be
people that want to knock you down so
your love then you're also equally you
hate it the more I love you the more
there's gonna be people away exactly and
so you're very vocal about anti-bullying
which is great tell people about that I
feel like oh I started an Instagram
campaign called I am more than and I
I've been bullied my whole life whether
it was about my peers or comments on
Instagram or Twitter whatever and I
never talked about my story really I
feel like I've kind of accepted it
because I realized that that's just
comes with the territory
so I kinda was online and just finding
other girls and boys my age
been bullied and have kind of overcome
it and just done something amazing with
it who inspired me so I kind of wanted
them to just use like my platform and
post their stories on Instagram to
hopefully inspire my followers to
because they inspire me so that's great
I have to say no matter no matter who
you are it hurts when people say bad
things without you no matter how
confident you are no matter how much you
have going on
it hurts and nobody deserves to be
bullied for any reason no matter what
you think of them you know that's my one
piece of advice if you're being bullied
is to one talk to somebody don't just
sit in the room and read comments or
listen to the haters or anything just
don't read anything if you don't read it
it can't harm you and just focus on
being successful and doing you and kill
them a success rule number six seize
your opportunities we're all very
excited with your lip kit by Kylie and
my first question is how did you come up
with that idea pretty much I've always
been obsessed with makeup and lip liner
specifically and I feel like my fans and
followers kind of knew me for over
lining my lips and getting the fuller
lip look yeah and every time I would
release what lip liner was using it'd be
completely sold out everywhere and I
couldn't ever get my own lip color so I
decided to take matters into my own
hands and just create my own and it's
like become a really big passion of mine
rule number seven find inspiration
meaning pen do not compete a lot of
people think we might but we just we
really like making like completely
different products and we both enjoy
each other's stuff so it's just the more
makeup the better Kim started filming
videos makeup tutorials before me
and I think the makeup artists that we
sometimes share was telling me that Kim
was shooting these videos and she was
using this certain light and it inspired
me to start shooting videos so Kim was
just doing a lot of fun stuff
and yeah it just inspired me to get it
going and make it as best as I can make
it
rule number eight have role models as we
send it back are you going to manage the
next generation of the kardashian-jenner
you know what I think everybody has to
do and you know in their life what they
love and I think that's what I have
found to be the most successful thing
for my girls my son my family is we all
do what we really love and that makes
purtz for me you know their success I
haven't learned everything from my mom
yet that I know that I need to she
teaches me something new every day about
everything she used my goals and I'm
just each day I'm like trying to take it
all in she's definitely been a huge part
of the success of Kylie cosmetics rule
number nine don't plan too far ahead
you're like the one I had or do you are
your last minute person and I would
describe yourself I'm definitely a last
minute person if I plan too far ahead
yeah I'll end up not wanting to do it so
I like to plan at the very last minute
so I can totally plan out my day and
rule number ten the last one before
special bonus clip is meet your fans so
if you guys don't know what we're doing
I did some research of some of the
biggest Kylie cosmetics supporters in LA
and I'm going around and hand delivering
my eyeshadow palettes before they come
out alright so we're at wood ranch about
to show up at this girl's work and give
her a pallet
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanted to give it to you
now I've got two very special bonus
clips from Kylie on how to find balance
and relax that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
time to move from watching a video to
actually taking some action in your life
or your business so answer these three
questions on your own at home talk about
them with a friend or leave your answers
in the comments below
here we go question number one what is
your inspiration to be great question
number two who is one of your role
models and what can you learn from them
this week and question number three what
are you different in and how will you be
proud of it thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
I think Kris Jenner is I mean - so smart
and she's run his empire for so long
that she runs a tight ship and with
Kylie I mean I think she's responsible
in her own way
let me just great team I'm worried about
you oh well you're just going it'll
really
crazy pace it's hard to balance like
being teenagers and also like running my
bestest I'm trying to just like laugh
and make memories I'm 19 and I really
want to just like live for myself if you
could go back in time what advice would
you give to your 11 year old self you
know worry about like a lot of things
like I have really bad anxiety so I
worry about like crazy things and I'd
probably try to help myself like with my
anxiety issues before it came you're
gonna go through a lot just be like it's
okay you'll get through it yeah how do
you handle criticism I do I feel like
I've been like have had a tension on me
since I was like 9 and when we started
the show
not as much obviously as now but look I
think I've been dealing with like not
only like kids from my school saying
stuff but like the whole world saying
stuff about me but now I just like read
it and it just like goes through one ear
not the other raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that that
people with passion and love one drop of
most self-worth depends on your it's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roaster
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details